il paraît que c'est compliqué avec ta
fille en ce moment
ne sois pas triste ils me détestent
s'ils ont passé du temps ensemble faut -
la paix elle est fragile et perturbée
quand j'étais gamine on racontait que la
vie d'à côté était une sorcière situe
frappait à sa porte
elle venait chercher pourtant portée
elle est revenue série ce sont des
légendes que dis-tu de ma soupe tous des
biomes qui a fait ça je pensais lui
échappe ici
du délire encore pourquoi pas retenu le
mal rôde autour d'elle impossible de
l'aider
[Musique]
sai baba yaga à démontrer anciens elle
surgit des enfers pour dévorer les âmes
innocentes suffit tu deviens dingue
qui êtes vous
fuyez